out of your mind here's the debate
[Music]
okay so for full disclosure this is not
pre-recorded right now is what time it
is 4 18 eastern standard time okay
andrew jenkins in the house presidential
former presidential candidate uh and the
leader of a new party he left the
democratic party started a party called
the forward party which you got a nice
little pin on your jacket andrew it's
great to have you on the podcast today
it is great to be here i have a
confession uh the reason i'm here is
because uh i noticed when you offered i
think it was five million dollars to get
obama together on stage and i was like
that's my kind of guy
[Laughter]
full disclosure we played we paid andrew
4.8 million to be here today but no it's
great to have you here man it's it's uh
it's uh
you you definitely shook up the world
with i believe we need to pay everybody
a thousand dollars a month ubi and
everybody lost their minds but i think
that kind of created a lot of momentum
and then you started explaining yourself
a different kind of podcast you went on
and then people had a decision to make
for themselves but for for the audience
that's listening that maybe doesn't know
your full background the past maybe take
one minute and before running for office
what did you do before running for
presidency
it's another reason why i'm here today
is that
before
i appeared on your tv screen
ready for president
i ran an education company now as a
private business uh grew to become
number one in the country and was bought
by a public company in 2009. so i'm an
entrepreneur an operator
uh and i
started a nonprofit in 2011 to train uh
what i i believe to be the next
generation of entrepreneurs through an
organization called venture for america
took me to the midwest and the south
uh and i saw firsthand that our economy
and our country is transforming in
various ways that you know good for some
people not good at all for other people
and that's why i ran for president was
to say look uh a technology and ai are
becoming more and more powerful it's
going to transform a way of life there
are some americans that are going to be
left behind so we need to think
it we need to think bigger about how
we're going to build the economy in the
future
and uh uh so so that happens and then
from there you run for office and then
you work for cnn and then i think early
october 2021 of last year you guys had a
breakup
and then you left the democratic party
to start a new political party tell us
how you came to that conclusion oh i'd
love to so running for president i
treated it like a startup and and when
people said to me it's like oh how are
you doing this to be like look when you
start something new you know this
patrick i mean i imagine a lot of people
listening to this know this
uh you're looking at devoting five to
ten years to make it work or to see if
it's going to work so in the context of
politics i was like it's three years and
i was like i can do anything for three
years you know three years a breeze
like worked at startups for a lot longer
than that uh so i learned a ton on the
trail and then after i came off the
trail i still had this sense of
foreboding or i was like it still feels
like our country is stuck
and so i i dug in uh and to try to
figure out why we feel so stuck and this
goes back to why i think you were trying
to get obama and trump together uh is
that it turns out our two-party system
is a big reason why we feel stuck uh you
have
a country that's more polarized than
ever if someone's for it then someone
else has to be against it 42 percent of
americans now see the other side as evil
don't want their kids to marry someone
of the other party i mean party is
taking the place of what used to be
religion in american life when you talk
about it
uh and so with this as the backdrop and
by the way it's one reason i appreciate
what you all do is that the media is
part of this social media is part of
this it's just trying to tribalize us
and separate us into camps and so i
concluded look
no matter what you're for the two-party
system is just going to make things
worse over time it's going to turn us
against each other you need to go back
to first principles and if you look at
the founding fathers of the u.s they
weren't freaking partisans or democrats
or republicans they thought political
parties were toxic and terrible
so the question is how do we get from
this dysfunctional duopoly to a more
functional system and i thought well you
need to start a functional third party
and then i i don't have it in me to be
like oh you should do this and then not
do it myself particularly if i'm one of
the most logical candidates to actually
do it
[Laughter]
so that's so this is during 2020 when we
were all inside for covid i was doing
this research and coming to this
conclusion that the us needs to get
beyond the two-party duopoly uh and move
toward to a multi-party system did you
ever have a meeting with michael porter
and katherine gayle cause that's also
what they talk about yes catherine on
like two years ago or year and a half
ago both of them on oh that they were a
profound influence on my thinking and
anyone who you should go back and listen
to that conversation you can also read
their book the politics industry
industry of politics i think some like
yeah i think it's a politics industry uh
where they break down
the politics industry as if it was a
business where you look at it and be
like okay like why does it seem so
dysfunctional why is so broken and what
they concluded was it's not that
politics is broken it's that politics
does not exist to actually solve
problems it exists to provide
jobs for politicians it exists to
provide jobs for consultants
it exists
for these media organizations to gin up
audiences
and so when you make that
leap where you're like okay the purpose
of politics is not actually to do good
things
then you conclude the same thing that
katherine and michael concluded and
those of you don't know michael's uh you
know harvard law professor who was one
of the godfathers of management
consulting uh and they concluded that
look the incentives are broken they need
to be fixed and what they recommend is
non-partisan open primaries to open it
up very interesting and then uh combine
that with the ranked choice voting
process you can choose whoever you want
so those two things are the foundation
of the forward party which i started
which is to say look
uh we just need to have a more
functional rational system that doesn't
uh amplify the extremes at the expense
of the 50 of us who are in the middle
somewhere you know when you first
started your campaign for new york
and uh to be the mayor i watched the
video by the way whoever cut the video
what a great video what a great you're
walking around the street you're talking
to people hot dog
basketball i think you were playing i
don't know what musical instrument you
were playing
i learned a lot about you and i said
this guy would be a very and i wanted
you to win oh thank you and i really
appreciate it you went from first the
first to fourth in winning mayor mayoral
you know as far as winning the city of
new york do you think
that was because
new york uh the politics in new york is
not ready for somebody like you and
maybe the power players didn't get
behind you or was it just maybe timing
or another reason why you couldn't
because day one i think everybody said
you were gonna win the whole thing
yeah uh first shout out to darren
aronofsky who's the director of that
video he also made a sick video yeah he
made uh
black swan and some other movies the
wrestler with mickey rourke you guys
haven't seen oh wow it's a professional
movie no no i'm telling you guys i've
seen a lot of great campaign videos
this is probably my favorite i've ever
seen it was that good yeah darren
aronofsky is a freaking you know one of
the best in the world um so uh i was out
campaigning during that time and i i
think that what turned against me at a
certain point was that
people just became concerned about crime
crime crime all the time
and that played to the advantage of eric
adams who had been a police officer uh
this despite the fact that i was
endorsed by both the
police captains and the firefighters
because they saw me as someone who was
going to be good on on these issues
uh but uh the i think the average voter
looked up and said former police officer
uh like
entrepreneur like you know the police
officer is gonna know more about how to
get crime under control because of the
timing it's kind of like when rudy ran
the one time
if he ran his campaign in a different
time he would have become president but
at the time he ran
even rudy giuliani in new york i'm
talking when he ran for president not
for mayor
he even said you know he made a comment
about lgbtq lgbt community and i was
like oh my god i can't believe you can
say something like this at a republican
that hurt him but same thing he ran on
if he would have ran 10 years later he
would have become depressed he would
have had a chance to win the whole thing
giuliani sometimes his timing and
campaign and what you're messaging of
your campaign is but knowing where you
are today
and having left the democratic party and
started a forward party
what are some things now
you
agree
that the left is doing right the
democrats are doing right what was
something where it's a tipping point to
say i'm just and i can't get behind that
and was there anything the republicans
are doing for you to say i'm not fully
there to say i'm a republican myself
but these are some of the things i do
agree with the republicans on what
they're doing all right so this is one
of the problems of the two-party system
is you have these kind of increasingly
ideological conversations and uh folks
on one side will be like hey government
should be doing all these things and
then uh the other side would be like no
government shouldn't be doing those
things and i think what most of your
listeners want is for government to
actually be good at the things it's
doing
[Laughter]
if you look at the press what is the
press always about in terms of these
political conversations how much money
is going to this how much money is going
to that wouldn't cut this we're going to
take that and then you're like where the
heck is this money going is it being
spent effectively why do i have the the
sinking feeling that you could power
more money into the system and it
wouldn't necessarily help during the
swamp one of the the clearest examples
of it in new york city
is there is a lot of money getting spent
in the new york city public school
system on uh educating these kids and
the results have not kept pace with the
investment and so if you look at this
and you go to someone on the left be
like hey what the problem what the
problem is they'll be like spend more
money and you're like i'm not really
sure that's gonna do it because you're
already spending whatever it is like
fifteen thousand ahead uh per year where
if you do the math on a you know
classroom of 30 kids you're like wait a
minute that's like a significant amount
of money and it's certainly not
uh bearing fruit
so this is what's missing from our uh
political discourse and i'm going to
suggest that this is what most business
people and entrepreneurs would naturally
do is like you show up you'll be like
okay
like how are we spending it what are we
getting in return
is it working is it efficient is it
accountable the fact is politicians just
kind of come and go money gets spent
they show up they cut a rib and they
announce a program does anyone actually
come back to see hey did that program
actually work did that bear bear fruit
no by the time
you know but by the time you get any
results of that the politicians moved on
everyone's moved on the press doesn't
actually drill about the efficacy of
these things
so so that's where i am
it genuinely is this middle road that i
think most americans have common sense
about it's like look should the
government be doing some things yes in
my opinion i mean i'm not like a you
know like
someone who thinks government should be
doing nothing but it should be doing
what it's doing at a much higher level
more effectively more accountably and
more efficiently do you think uh i look
up the top
if you want to pull out the greatest
third party candidates of all time okay
for most you know who's the greatest
third party candidate of all time
probably ross perot ross pro you know
tom who would you put as a greatest
republican candidate i'm sorry the the
third party candidate of all time in
terms of effectiveness and polling and
acceptance i think in my lifetime it's
been ross pro
you know you know who it is if you think
about it it's abraham lincoln abraham
lincoln amen
the exact same thing though i just
discovered it because he's the first
republican there was no republican
abraham lincoln is the greatest third
party there was like democrats and wigs
right yeah the republican party was the
brand new startup party when lincoln
wins in 1860 with 39.8 percent of the
vote
you know
there were four candidates right and now
you don't think about it because you're
like oh republicans one of the two major
parties but they were brand new in 1860
and here's another wrinkle when he runs
for a re-election in 1864 his vice
presidential
uh candidate is from the other party he
ran a unity ticket where he's the
republican
has nobody done that since then i feel
like there's a a a yearning for
something like that i feel like if a
republican and a democrat worked
together and showed that they can get
along the country would be dude that's
amazing i love it well who did that tom
who who is it that lieberman who was it
that did john mccain tiptoed around
having joe lieberman and the democrat
joined him and then he ended up choosing
sarah palin yeah and i talked to someone
about that decision who actually got a
call from john mccain at the time being
like hey what do you think if i uh
choose joe lieberman
and the the political calculation was
not there for him it's like he thought
that
sarah palin was going to help more
politically but it was a real missed
opportunity
when you were running for office and you
were kind of going through it and you
know you got everybody on the kamala
harris you got elizabeth warren you got
bernie got all these guys after
everybody's offstage who did they kind
of like brush you off like listen you're
not part of this industry so who are you
here you're gonna you're not gonna make
it anyways or did any of the candidates
try to befriend you have side
conversations with you have calls with
you have meetings with you dinner with
you because potentially you could be a
star how were you treated
uh it evolved over time we had some uh
jokes on the trail where it's it's all
fun and games until andrew yang passes
you in the polls
so
so the candidates who were really really
like tier one
were were just about always good to me
because they're like hey you know i
don't feel threatened by yang this is in
16 hillary this is 20.
2019. um there were some candidates who
were kind of dicks to me uh honestly but
they tended to be the second tier
candidates who were kind of insecure
about their uh you know like their own
campaign trajectory are these any dicks
you can reveal or no i don't want to be
a jerk myself you know um so i remember
one who would be second time i remember
like i remember something very
specifically sorry i got my years away
it was 20 20. i remember you were
pulling it three percent
more than beto
but he somehow made it on to
something on cnn do you remember this
you know what i'm talking about yeah
there's a period when the press was
definitely like okay let's try and like
fudge you know this yang uh campaign's
numbers
where they'd have like a graphic up and
then i'd raise i'd raise more than
people that were on the graphic and it's
like hey guys that doesn't seem right um
so beto and i were always cool maybe
because he and i are both gen x uh since
there are probably some other xers uh
here
um so i always get along with beto i
always get along with cory booker uh you
know like um most of the candidates down
the stretch
patrick became genuinely friendly
because i was on seven debate stages so
you're like seven you can't be a jerk to
someone over and over again you know
what i mean
someone must have pissed you off for you
to start your own third party andrew
like someone must someone must have said
something or done something you said you
know what
i just can't do this anymore you know
the problem isn't anything in terms of
personal interaction the problem is that
everyone is stuck and then even if
you're a successful politician within
let's say the democratic party you're
stuck you know
like your uh behavior is constrained
your policy positions are constrained
uh and uh you know you have a ton of
masters to serve uh and um you know
media complex that that's going to be
pushing you in a particular direction
uh i'm a problem solver you know like i
i don't know if you all sense this like
i don't really care about like you know
my own political advancement but anyone
who's in that system all of a sudden
does care and you know the big thing
that people underestimate is that they
get surrounded by dozens of professional
political operatives who also have their
careers on the line you know it's like
hey we need you to do this and that
because
uh you know we need to get better jobs
ourselves or you know we need to be able
to go on to the next gig
um and that's one thing i appreciate
about the folks who worked on my
campaign is most of them were not
careerists in that way until we raised
we ended up raising 40 million dollars
so after we passed like you know 20 25
million the freaking consultants came
out of the woodwork uh all of a sudden
they were like hey i like them here we
can make some money here now yeah yeah
we're here to help and this is the thing
that also you know as a business guy at
first i was like frankly like you know
we don't need these consultants like
where were they you know like six months
ago um but then when you're in a
position where you have to spend eight
million dollars on tv ads in iowa you do
hire the consultants because you're like
well hey i'm not gonna like start from
scratch like yeah yeah at that point
then it's like well how do i do this
professionally but that's the smart move
to do i think you do need to bring some
people up it's like a company when the
company's doing a million two million
three million maybe you can manage it
when it starts doing 20 30 40 million
you kind of need to start bringing some
of the c-suite executives who know how
to put systems
infrastructure you know protocols all
that stuff so that that kind of makes
sense yeah but but the point is that
like the the system is going to keep
producing certain kinds of uh candidates
and certain kinds of results and like to
me that's not going to solve the problem
andrew going back to it so
uh forward party how much momentum have
you had ever since you announced it it's
been tremendous because more and more
people are waking up to the reality that
the current two-party system is not
working and it's not going to deliver
what you want no matter what you want
it's not going to deliver unless what
you want is people to go crazy and get
more and more upset at each other if
that's what you want it's going to
deliver that because it's delivering
that in a hell of a way yeah it's going
to deliver that um so more and more
people go to fordparty.com every day
they sign up they volunteer uh they
donate and we have some really exciting
announcements coming up so it's a good
feeling because patrick you've been a
part of these growth stories you know
when you you have product market fit and
you feel like okay like we're going to
grow from here that's been the feeling
is the ultimate goal to eventually be a
president is that kind of what you're
solving for where there is because you
said something very very important at
the beginning you said i treat this like
a startup and it's a 10-year plan right
okay that changes perspectives which
means
if you're going for 10 years the world
kind of just watched you play and that
was kind of like uh you know whatever
you want to call it all-star game people
like okay this guy can actually play
good for him he's got the talent to be
on the stage seven debates nobody's
gonna be on seven debates and you were
blobbing on being seven debates and they
kind of didn't want you to be on there
so you weren't afraid to go up against
them and you were talking [ __ ] which was
great
and then you were also proposing hey
this short to format debate two minute
answers is not necessary we need
something a little bit more long-form so
i can really explain what i'm doing and
all this stuff which people started
listening to maybe this guy's got a
point maybe this guy's got a point but
are you now saying okay i went for this
people noticed you know what this guy
can hang maybe next i go for you know
mayor senator governor congress and then
eventually in 10 years i'm going to go
be a president what is that vision or
the next five moves with you yeah
my vision is to try and get this country
through a really difficult time uh
because if you fast forward not even
that long i mean we all saw what
happened on january 6th uh last year uh
unfortunately i don't think that's a
one-time event i think that you're
you're going to see us slipping towards
more consistent
uh
unrest and political strife and violence
and so when you ask what my plan is my
plan is to do everything i can to to
keep us functional and shore it up to
your
enthusiasm about a unity ticket i would
be super pumped about a unity ticket uh
now i'm going to convey to you all like
are people actually talking about a
unity ticket behind the scenes yes they
are you know like am i going to do
everything i can to help usher that into
being yes i will so
i'm about trying to solve problems even
now
i will say like i don't really care that
much if i die
x years from now never having been
present united states i mean that was
true even when i was running for
president united states you know i
didn't go home and you know be like
bemoaned to my wife it's not your dream
you know i'm like the child of
immigrants who's trying to do right by
my country
uh and it's just not doing very well
uh you know what that kind of reminds me
of a slight like uh when they asked
chris paul or westbrook so let me ask
you a question if you retire playing nba
and you never make the win the
championship you're okay with that yeah
because i go to a beautiful family i
make 18 million dollars you're xyz it's
okay if i make it or not and then
they're fans get so furious how could
you say that yeah i want somebody to
want to win the championship andrew you
got to tell me if i ever win i would be
you know that whole scene with the uh
trump and oprah where uh oprah says do
you have any plans of ever running for
office you've seen this before a million
times and not a million times but you
know it's all over the place and he says
i don't know bro but if i ever did i
would win because i'm a winner right the
idea is people want to get behind
somebody that's saying hey if you vote
for me i'll be able to do xyz so for you
if we go 10 years from now let's fast
forward ideal place where you think you
can contribute the most
is it more in the free market i'm gonna
go be a media personality do that like
you did at cnn is it gonna be more
behind the scenes
leading a third party and helping
somebody become president or no
frontrunner i'm gonna be the talent and
the voice and getting in there getting
dirty to help make some real changes in
this country and to do that you kind of
need to fight to get at the highest
level of office if you're going to make
some real change
where would that be what's the most
likelihood of seeing andrew in which of
these situations uh i i don't think our
current structures are going to solve
our problems in the time that we have
and so i'm laser focused on trying to
make it so that they could one of my
great fears so there's a period you know
running for president uh you know
thousands of people coming out uh to see
me and support me and like you feel like
wow people are really investing their
hopes for the future in me
and one of my concerns was to your point
patrick that you get in there and you
can't actually deliver for them why
because the system is not set up to
allow you to actually solve their
problems either because the politics
aren't there the party mechanics or our
government itself
um and so that's what we have to try and
resolve
uh quickly because
um the problems aren't going away in my
opinion the problems are actually
speeding up somewhat
so of those things you named i think
it's going to be around this
third party movement democracy reform
right now as we're having this
conversation 62 percent of americans
want to move on from the duopoly and if
you go back to the business
metaphor if you showed up at a
marketplace and there were two providers
and 62 percent of people wanted a choice
you would start a third provider
immediately maybe a fourth one a fifth
one too um now in this marketplace the
two companies have said no no no like
you can't have a third choice uh you
know we're going to keep you from being
on the ballot we're going to ignore you
in the media we're going to like have
um you know we're going to sue you like
whatever the heck heck it is
um but the
the truth of it is that 62 of people
want a choice and i'm saying like well
let's get you that choice then because
if you get that choice it's going to be
good for the country so is it is it a
problem with the current duopoly
the two-party system or the current
iteration of the two-party system
because we have other parties with the
libertarian party the green party etc
etc but you're watching a sort of
reformation within the parties
themselves post-trump is it is it the
two-party system or the current
iteration of it
uh the the current iteration of it's the
worst version of it and unfortunately
it's going to get worse um so
uh if you were to rewind
50 years or so the two parties were
actually somewhat indistinguishable uh
you know like it wasn't as dramatic
there wasn't this left right thing it
was like you know like democrat
republican were kind of
uh different
flavors of uh of you know
vanilla
it would be like
you know french vanilla versus just
plain vanilla um
that changed over the last number of
years where you ended up with um with it
getting combined with you know different
factors whether it's urban rural whether
it's racial whether you know um it's
economic
um and so this version of the two-party
system is possibly the worst
um but i say that believing that it's
going to get worse still
so
um so you have you know this this
version is our founding father's
nightmare come to life
regarding the forward party i mean quite
candidly everyone
you were very likable people started to
see what you were doing and
lo and behold boom boom yang gang you
know gang gang everyone loved it it was
fun to say you're a fun guy
people like to say that and it kind of
built up who you are
now with this forward party who is part
of the yang gang who is the forward the
cornerstone of the forward party like in
the
electorate who's out there that's like
yo yang gang forward party this is us
yeah so the the forward party early
adopters have been people who are fed up
with the two-party system and those
people
tend to overlap very heavily with
business owners entrepreneurs operators
tech people i was just at the bitcoin
conference so it was good so folks who
are into bitcoin libertarians are
definitely in there too um uh and so i i
joke that it's like a tribe of the
people that uh
are concerned about excessive tribalism
you know what i mean and that that tribe
of people tends to be
these like rational pragmatic business
types
this is you though everything he's
describing business owners operators
free thinkers
you know libertarian almost
what's your hesitancy to maybe being
like yo
yang gang it up forward party like what
what's the flaws and what's going on we
haven't even gotten into that yet i mean
that's a whole different conversation to
have no for me
uh uh
here's where i would go with this all i
think of everything with me is
sequencing you know you've been around
me long enough to know what sequencing
is so
if his goal is to make forward party a
real household name okay hey i left the
democratic party to start the forward
party here's who i am and i left cnn
october 2021 and i'm doing a forward
party okay
you have to have a man who was on bill
maher five days ago so you have to have
the platform to get the eyeballs for the
right people to keep seeing it right
that's why and he's got it he's being
picked up but i wonder if this is
president this is where he's at today
is there four steps before getting here
and it's the mistake if he goes
automatically to here so
we may you know like somebody may say no
he can't do that well why can't he do
that well trump did it but trump already
had a massive audience you know
apprentice business success well he's an
entrepreneur not at trump's level well
he was on tv not necessarily before he
ran for office because he didn't have an
apprentice so that's the part where what
needs to happen in between because if
you don't
you know there india's got 45 political
parties how many of them do we know 45
50 political parties so you and i can go
start a political party tomorrow but to
really make a third party like him that
he's talking about really excel george
jorgensen is going to be here tomorrow
why is she here tomorrow because jojo
was like hey this libertarian concert
makes a lot of sense how come it hasn't
taken off and that libertarian 90 of
crypto is all libertarian that's who
they are they see themselves as
libertarian how come there's not been a
candidate that's blown up on the
libertarian side you got john mcafee
okay who else do we have johnson's joe
jorgensen and all this stuff but how
come no one's taken off
there i think there is some steps in
between
to your point patrick uh
if you look at the democratic and
republican party they have this giant
media infrastructure behind them so if
you wanted a third party movement you
probably need a parallel uh
infrastructure they have a donor network
you would need one of those they have
various uh influencers
parroting talking points which you don't
necessarily want people parroting but
so so that there's like this massive
infrastructure that needs to get built
um
and
in my view and i actually have this
experience every single day because of
what i'm doing there are more and more
americans who are like okay i get it
like we need to build uh this parallel
uh party infrastructure you know let me
roll my sleeves and get to it and some
of those people are you know like folks
who were republicans or democrats or
just like that this is not going to work
as it is
as you were out campaigning you know you
go out you run for president and like
any startup here's our business plan and
you're not certain about it because this
this and this or the best knowledge and
the best estimates and the best guesses
you can make about going into it what
surprised you about
opinions perspectives or realities about
the voters once you got all the way out
into the primaries and now you're really
seeing people you know 500 people in a
gymnasium in iowa you get a lot of
first-hand feedback what surprised you
when you went out versus what the
business plan was
what's funny is how accurate the
business plan was generally speaking so
what i would say to folks when they were
saying hey you're running for president
can you do that blah blah blah look one
critical success factor in this whole
thing is just can you get 40 000 iowans
on board
um because that would have you win the
caucus and then they hear that and be
like 40 000. that doesn't sound like
that many but it turns out only 6.4
percent of iowans participate in the
democratic caucus so you like slice that
electorate pretty quick
um so 40 000 i think you know bernie
ended up winning with 41 000 so the
business plan was accurate in terms of
the the general uh goal and the
parameters what surprised me about those
folks when i got out there in real life
was stuff that i actually could have
figured out beforehand so i should not
have been surprised by it um but they
were older average age of a caucus goer
might have been you know 50 to 55.
uh that they were
um
uh
very very heavy cable news watchers for
the most part
um like that there was like a a bit of
an institutional vibe to the voters that
i still felt myself to be somewhat
surprised by
uh and because of that ordinarily like
that the kind of change that i was
proposing like would take longer than
one cycle because of the nature of those
primary voters if you look at the young
voters in iowa i won the iowa
youth poll i'm the first candidate to
have ever won that poll and not win the
the actual thing first candidate ever to
win the youth poll but not win the
actual
yeah so they'd cut off voting at
approximately 19 i you know probably
would have won that thing so
but i so do your point about like the
the the surprise it was that there is
something of a delay
um because you're talking primarily to
50 and 60 year old voters
andrew let me ask you uh did you uh
i don't know if you this is public
information or not did you vote for joe
biden is that who you voted for uh yeah
okay so how do you think he's doing
i think that it is not a great time in
america right now and i i hear from
folks who are close to joe um and
there's a sense that you know his
energies are not what they uh they they
could be um that his team sometimes
doesn't trust him to freelance uh and so
when he goes into a meeting like there
are you know not
traditional negotiations
in the way that you would want them to
be
so i you know that if you look at it
from the outside you're like hey like
you know i'm not sure
um if he has the energy and the
wherewithal and i think those concerns
are very real
okay um so
let's there's a candidate that you you
uh uh
remind me of okay and let me kind of
throw this out there and you can trash
my idea as much as you wanna so you have
no clue what the hell you're talking
about patrick okay
um you remind me of herman mccain okay
okay let me permanently okay my bad
herman king not
herman mckinnon he said harold earlier
so herman cain okay the whole family
here's why you remind me of herman cain
okay and if you're not familiar with
herman cain yeah i don't think they look
anything alike no no no no not on looks
at him not visual oh my gosh no no not
looks at all by the way he passed away
during covet i think 20 20. i i totally
i totally get it but
[Music]
yeah so he came up with this campaign
and he said nine nine well we heard it a
billion times there were nine nine nine
if god only wants me to tie ten percent
why should the government want more than
god that's why it's nine percent federal
nine state and nine you know sales tax
whatever the 999 was
and you sat there you're like
that kind of makes sense
cool let's go with it you know okay
i like herman cain 999 this is fantastic
and the next thing you know boom he goes
like this and then it was boom like this
republican by the way republican totally
he was a former ceo businessman you know
uh a god of fathers godfather's pizzas
so then when you do the math you're like
yeah i don't know if this 999 thing is
going to work out or not so you came out
and you said ubi okay
thousand dollars a month you know
because i agree with elon musk and
here's the direction we're going and
we need to do a thousand dollar ubi okay
so some people are like i kind of like
that idea it's kind of like milton
friedman when he said reverse
income yeah then the way hey but you got
to contribute to do this and you look at
the way he explained it slightly
different yours yours you don't
necessarily have to earn a thousand his
you have to earn to give back to get
some kind of a money from the government
okay fine i see where the idea is coming
from
and then the last two years we actually
got ubi and we realized it doesn't work
and here's why
so forty percent of america's uh money's
been printed the last two years whatever
the numbers you've seen it i've seen it
we've seen it all over the place okay so
where did the money flow we send this
1200 oh my god it's gonna change
people's lives what we realize is low
and middle income families the reason
why they're there sometimes because they
don't have the right financial habits
they don't know how to save they spend
they're you know putting back into the
market they're buying products and it
goes back to the business owners oh my
god amazon he got richer oh my god elon
musk he got so rich how did he become
300 billion oh my god all these
billionaires and all these well yeah
because ubi money always flows back to
the rich so
you can trash whatever i said and said
patrick you're wrong because of xyz
we're now here this is april of 2022. we
bought into ubi a few years ago saying
maybe this man's got a good idea let's
pay attention to just like we did with
herman cain now that we're here and we
know we tested ubi the last two years at
the federal level not just nebraska not
just these nebraska alaska or some of
the smaller markets that we're testing
where is your opinion now with ubi
uh so i want to unpack what we've done
over the last couple of years the vast
majority of the money that went out to
folks was an enhanced unemployment
benefits
and those benefits were tied to not
working uh i i've always thought that's
a terrible way to go you don't want ever
to tie funds to someone not working
if anything you'd want to somehow tie
incentives to work into it instead of
having a very powerful disincentive so
that's number one number two over 80
percent of the you know 1.7 trillion
dollar cares act or this other stuff was
nowhere near
uh these little checks that people got
83 of that money went to banks
airlines uh cruise companies you name it
uh the financial system itself they just
plowed hundreds of billions of dollars
uh into the financial system they did
not send that stuff out as checks to
people
um so
if you start picking out the way that
the money actually got into people's
hands one thing that i am very much for
was this enhanced child tax credit like
that stuff brought kids out of poverty
you know it actually apparently like
helped keep a million people working
because when they took it away then they
couldn't afford child care so they don't
go to work anymore so they stay home
with a kid like is that a win
um so that the the things that are are
being put out there right now
um are still in my view like not
designed in a way that you would expect
to yield positive results and then some
of the results you know i would be the
first to say i'd look at it and be like
look
this should have been done differently
designed better uh and uh
uh and
positioned so that more people were able
to pursue opportunities
uh not provide incentives for them not
to do so if you ran this midterm and
you're running let's just say you had
you're running for some let's just say
you're running 2024 2023 right
would you still run on thousand dollars
a month ubi or would your campaign be
different
well right now
uh
my focus is trying to set up the third
party movement for success if it were
andrew yang presidential candidate like
do i still believe in ubi yes i do i
believe in some version of it i do think
that we need to
reformat the way the government
administers a lot of this stuff i think
the current disability programs and
welfare programs are not well designed
and are are
on that they are attaching various uh
negative incentives and i found that out
when i was out campaigning where a woman
like two women like 20 women like you
know 20 men
would say to me hey
um i am scared to volunteer at my local
church because i'm afraid someone's
going to see see me as able-bodied i'm
going to lose my benefits hey i want to
work part-time but like if i work
part-time they're going to take this
like child payment away from me i heard
those stories all the time
and in my mind like we should be putting
people in position to succeed and not be
afraid to volunteer work part-time what
happened with
because what you're talking about is
federal stimulus right and then some of
the unemployment was federal and also um
state but i think you actually did a ubi
test case in the bronx you had a million
bucks you gave them to
500 low income there's a thousand
families a thousand okay a thousand
families so what happened with that
also that was the beginning of the
pandemic and that was just an emergency
measure where it's like look uh you know
we have to just try and keep people from
um
you know like starving or
in in that case there was a period when
uh you know people weren't sure
uh whether the government was going to
do anything so i was like oh yeah i got
a million bucks like let's just send it
out to some families in the bronx we did
get some very very positive results from
that we actually ended up tying i'll
tell you guys the stories because it's
kind of funny so it's it's actually
harder to give away a million bucks than
you think
um
andrew i'm willing to try it out if you
want to give it over here i mean you be
on me out all right so check it out
first thing i do is i call uh senior
people at citibank and jpmorgan chase
being like hey can you identify like a
thousand struggling families in the
bronx
um and then they take a couple days and
get back to me and said no we can't and
you're like you do realize i'm just
trying to give your customers money like
you know and they're like no no privacy
regulatory et cetera and i was talking
to senior people it wasn't like i was
talking to you know the back teller
you're in a vault mary how are you i
have a million bucks here so then my
second thing is like hey can you just
like send me a thousand bank debit cards
for your bank for a thousand bucks each
like you'd think they might be able to
do that and i was like i'll find a way
to get those into people's hands and
they couldn't do that either
but being an entrepreneur in parallel
the whole time i was talking to various
uh community orgs and i found one
neighborhood trust that uh helps provide
financial literacy and services to uh
working uh poor
and i said can you find me a thousand
families and they said not only can we
find you a thousand families but we have
their bank account information and we
can sit down with each and every one of
them and give them a financial literacy
coaching session and then we said done
we went that direction so that's the way
we ended up distributing the money and
it you know a lot of positive results
but by the way just
if you don't mind real quick what is the
basic foundation like if i'm part of the
forward party what do i believe in so
the forward party has six tenants um the
the tenants i think everyone's going to
be like oh that's totally reasonable so
it's uh
open primaries ranked choice voting
uh human-centered economy which is like
hey like we should matter in addition to
to um how the the giant companies are
doing
uh fact-based governance so it's you
should agree on some facts
that's like that you know you'd think
that would be uh you know uh obvious but
it's it's not
um the fifth is ubi and then the sixth
is grace intolerance which is look you
can disagree with me
uh we're all americans we're all human
beings
uh like we shouldn't be like demonizing
each other counseling each other
uh treating someone like they are worth
less than us if they have a different
point of view you're not a censorship
guy you don't believe in censorship
no i mean you know it's like trump
should be on twitter so babylon b should
be on twitter so those guys should be on
twitter
you know so the the twitter thing it's
it's rough because
twitter is a private company you know
it's like if you're a private company
and then we put you in a position where
it's like hey you're now like the public
commons uh you know but here are these
rules
um so
i i'm a free speech guy like i think
that people should not be afraid frankly
to hear points of view that are
different from from them and that this
fact that we've kind of
uh you know degenerated to a point where
we liken
uh the these words to like uh physical
attacks and whatnot like i don't think
that's productive
um but it's a it's a tough one with
these tech companies because we're
treating them like they're public
commons and they're you know that
they're just like a private firm that's
traded on this documentary i don't
disagree with you when prager and uh his
wife sue were going through a prager
university they said companies are not
held at the same liability same
standards as the government is for
freedom of speech but say you were
sitting on a board seat okay of twitter
and you're one of 11 voices okay and
they're talking about we want to take
trump down because he's offending a lot
of people people are getting upset would
you vote for him to be taken down or
staying on well it wouldn't be based on
him offending a lot of people if it was
something where he was inciting violence
and there was something you know like
there was actually like a direct threat
of harm then you know you you would take
him off if it was like hey you're saying
things that people don't like then you'd
leave it alone andrew then why is
khamenei still on twitter
uh you know i mean that that's why he's
still on twitter why are some i'm from
iran and i see some of the stuff i'm
like i totally get it if you're like you
know if if you're my father
and you're consistent with me and my
sister and my brother i'm cool totally
get it my dad's gonna
but if you're not
then you're full of [ __ ] so now your
is not there so you're okay with putin
being on but you guys are calling
putin's the worst thing and amazon but
trump is off and trump was a u.s
president do you know like let me put it
to you this way
from another country i wasn't born here
you were born here if i see you from
another country you're more worried
about your own president but you're
worried you're not worried about my
ruler
russia or china or iran you're going to
get your ass handed to you because of
how soft you guys are you're your own
enemy you seem so weak if i look at it
from another country standpoint i would
just sit there and say america's coming
down going down because they can't even
get on the same page together well i
mean to your point uh you know there are
a ton of foreign governments who are
uh
uh enjoying you know access to our
social media companies and the rest of
it um and you know i would agree with
you that i'm sure our standards are all
over the place when it comes to
different actors from different places
uh
yeah you know i mean it's an unenviable
position for some of the the the tech
companies when i talk to them and i'm
friendly with some of them
um i'm friendly with elon too who's now
the biggest shareholder of
twitter uh you know some of them have
said look like having us be the arbiter
of like what uh you know uh is fair game
and what isn't like isn't a position
even we want to be in like you know
we're running a business we want to just
like make money and not you know like
not be on in you know the the the
decision makers and all this stuff so
some of them were like maybe we start
like a council it's not our board where
you have
uh media
non-profits
journalism government others and then
you know like it's like a more
collective decision the tough part there
is that
a lot of these decisions are being made
instantaneously they're being made by ai
because you know you're talking about
you know whatever billions of messages
pat you know what would be good for you
to ask andrew if you want to what's that
the question that you ask
of the five things
he would be a great person let's see
what he's gonna say so who do you think
has the most power in america today okay
five uh organizations and individuals
who's got the most power
the richest people in america
billionaire class president of united
states
virtual governments which is like
twitter youtube google facebook those
guys our educational system or
mainstream media i'll say it one more
time
riches billionaires in america president
mainstream media virtual government or
our educational system from first to
last who's got most power who's got
leased
well this is fun
or from least to first or whatever you
do
i'd say i'd say number one is big tech
uh you know i mean they're nation states
unto themselves they're number one we're
on the same page i agree with them i
think i think facebook has two billion
folks i mean that's
that's very very significant
uh
num number two uh the
one that popped into my mind was like
the billionaire class it was like the
jeff bezos's of the world it overlaps
with big tech
um so elon musk just bought nine percent
yeah so elon like uh
um but you know i i would flip-flop
between like the billionaire class and
the president um because the president
does have some very very vast powers
uh you know obviously they can
make world history changing decisions
where foreign policy is concerned
military intervention
but even domestically
you know like there there's a massive
impact so you know i could be talked
into either one of those as
uh two you could see them think of them
as in a way it depends upon the
president it depends on the president
depends on the billionaires
uh and then
um mainstream media foreign educational
system five wow you put educational
system last yeah yeah i did why is that
you know i mean it's it's a tough thing
to say but you know like the the
educational system
i wish it were higher which i mean i'm a
parent we all got two kids you know nine
and six
um but but you you look at it and it
strikes me as really
uh remember the question is influence
influence who's got the most influence
you think educational system has the
least influence out of the five
more than less than mainstream media
yeah i do
really unpack that why
well so the so kids go to school and my
kids are a little young so i could
change my perspective when they get
older my kids are nine and six uh you
know they get certain messages and
inputs they get some messages and inputs
from me and my my wife
um
but i see the impact that mainstream
media has every day
uh on
our politics our public discourse and
you know like when it turns on a
particular person or organization like
it really does
uh end up moving in in concert in tandem
and it could be too that uh i just went
through
a couple of media ringers uh you know
myself when i was running for president
and like the mainstream media had like a
certain treatment
uh and so it could just be that i was
closer to it but with your you put
education last which pat is a little
shocked by but i've seen you
i've listened to you i think it might
have been on rogan talking about student
debt and the education college system
and basically the burden that it is and
you did your math and how much the you
know oh yeah
i think we're up to like you know 1.9
trillion in school debt uh the cost of
college has gone up 250 percent since i
went
and my joke was it's not like you got
250 better in that time you know
probably got significantly worse
um so so you do have this onerous system
um you know uh 65 of americans don't go
to college
uh and you could say that you know that
that that's um
uh
because they they you know couldn't
afford it but there are a lot of people
that you know college colleges isn't the
right fit
um so i think that that maybe is another
reason why like i answered the way i did
is because like there's this vast vast
universe of people that
like you know
like after they graduate from high
school they're like all right good to go
and then they head out into the world
yeah i think i think a president is i
may be wrong but i think president's the
least because you only got eight years i
think education is one of the highest
not necessarily the highest because
you got 20 30 40 years of indoctrinating
the next generation of people that are
coming up mainstream media is not as
powerful as they used to be they're
going to be lower because virtual
governments have taken over
billionaires hey you piss off elon you
can go buy something you piss off jeff
bezos he can go by wapo and then write
an article talking about the fact that
if you're on musk by twitter you're
going to lose freedom of speech and they
talk [ __ ] to each other right which is
hilarious to say elohim is going to take
freedom of speech away from you andrew
be very careful an innovator could do
that to you but yeah that's why i think
education are you saying that that
someone like individual like an elon
musk
is more powerful than a trump
the wrong elon musk with the wrong
intentions is very dangerous to the
world if you think about it the wrong
guy with that kind of money that's a
very dangerous position to be it's it's
it's meaning so let me and this is how
like it's not the guy that made his
money because elon made his money
working his ass off but if he lands one
of his kids when he dies gets 1.9
trillion dollars and he's never worked
for anything that's a scary thought
right there on what that kid's capable
of doing do you have a family yourself
you have kids who are four kids ten
eight uh five and nine months wow yeah
you got nine and six i got i got a full
household yeah you're an overachiever
man yeah i would have 20 if i could i'd
have 20 kids if i could what do you
think about tulsi gabbard what do you
think about tulsi you know chelsea and i
got along well on the trail um so that's
one of the underrated things about that
set of experiences is that you know it's
like people respond to us and you've
probably met a lot of us so you know to
us you're we're hum to you we're human
beings but um you know to each other
it's like i've hung out with tulsi and
her husband abraham you know like a
dozen times and the sticks of new
hampshire are just like you know waiting
to go on in the union hall or whatnot
so so
uh you know she and i um uh became quite
friendly why do you think
the left doesn't support her i mean you
got a woman
who is marketable you got a democrat you
got a military she's young
great speaker very good communicator why
do you think the establishment doesn't
elevate somebody like her why do you
think they don't like somebody like her
it was very obvious oh i mean
she had like an open feud going with
hillary yeah going back and forth yeah
she calls her a russian asset
whether he calls tulsi that yeah uh so
i'll just tell you know a story that
might be fun and bring everyone back but
i was actually standing between chelsea
gabriel and kamala harris on the debate
station they're going at it it was
almost a comfortable thing i was like
you know you can actually probably
rewind that footage and see me being
like just like my head go back and forth
like in the moment are you actually
uncomfortable oh i wasn't uncomfortable
i was like oh my gosh like i can't
believe i'm standing between these two
people um you know going going after you
why do you think so but by the way i got
to tell you
folks i want to give andrew yanks a lot
of credit here i got to give you credit
in my mind i'm trying to calculate how
many questions you actually directly
answered i want to say it's less than 50
percent you become a bro you become a
pro and i pride myself
you become
listen there's coaching to to running
for office and you got to figure out a
way and and you've you've given the
politically correct diplomatic answer
nothing that's going to rub anybody the
wrong way so you're playing it safe the
way you're going which maybe it's a
political strategy you got i don't know
maybe you don't want to get that kind of
publicity with all of a sudden andrew
yanks said the following on this podcast
and he pisses five you know 50 000
people up and you don't want to have
that happen to you but your audience is
bigger than that i'm kidding
but but i want to ask you i want to ask
you like specifically why do you think
they don't support somebody like tulsi
why not get behind somebody like tulsi
the the way that the media builds up uh
their take on candidates uh you know is
born of a number of things i think for
tulsi
um
she
came out as being against certain
establishment positions relatively early
and then when some reporters went and
tried to
spend time with her you know like some
of the treatment was not good and so you
ended up developing like this really
adversarial relationship which as a
candidate uh you know it's tough because
you feel like if if i sit down with you
and have a conversation with you and
like we have an interview and then the
article comes out and it's
mean and negative then you're like oh
like i spent some time and i tried to
you know like open myself up some and
then you were
kind of harsh to me so let me stop doing
that and then you stop doing that and
then you know what happens
another harsh article comes out
because you're not willing
to talk to the person so so uh so those
things can build up
um pretty pretty quick uh and tulsi
uh i think marches to her own
um her own beat and everyone sensed that
and so when she would be willing to take
on certain establishment figures i think
that made it worse with the press and
that's not a compliment to the press
part of that the fact that she had beef
with
the lady in charge hillary clinton and
they were like uh uh buddy like you're
barking up the wrong tree or her
uh going after kamal on the debate stage
and i think that was another thing
or tulsi can you imagine like
um
the two on how they deliver messages
kamala versus tulsi a hundred at a
hundred times
tulsi is going to do laps around kamal
do you think so
a thousand had a thousand times do you
agree in a methodology delivering
message now he may disagree with it i
don't know
he was in the state on stage with the
both of them they would know they're
different types of figures they're
different types of messengers uh you
know that they are i've seen them both
speak like uh an awful lot of times most
of the time in a forum where no one else
was paying any attention it was like you
know those are the best though yeah you
know um uh it it it was
a fascinating process i recommend if
this thing happens again which it will
in 24 it's like just spend a weekend in
in uh new hampshire or iowa if you're
close to other things because you can
see all the candidates up close in new
hampshire in new hampshire i'll tell you
a random story as a hollywood story kind
of you know before we do that i just
want to say this folks if you do want to
call them we're going to take some calls
the last 15 minutes so if you do want to
if you do have a call and send us a text
at 3103-401132
we may take a few callers is that the
number that we do or what's the number
first post the number so they can see go
ahead and you were saying i was saying
so uh paul giamatti you know the actor
actor yeah
like he just drove up to new hampshire
for a weekend and just went from uh
event to event just saw you know half a
dozen presidential candidates including
me
um and so that's the kind of thing i was
like that's really smart because you
could actually see people up close and
personal
if you just invest a couple days
so that's something you can do in either
iowa or new hampshire i think andrew
yang just gave us an idea 2024 will be
in new hampshire andrew do you think
dude that's a good idea having been in
business yourself you know there's
uh there's different number ones number
twos number three is number fours and
number fives and companies right and
somebody may be a good number one of a
10 million auto company but they're
number eight of a hundred million dollar
company somebody may be a number one of
a hundred million dollar company but our
number four of a billion auto company
somebody may be number one of a billion
auto company but a number two of a 50
billion auto company like there's levels
to life right
do you see yourself as a number one of
the united states of america can you see
yourself being the number one decision
maker president
of the united states of america oh yeah
i can see that for sure and i can see
that even more so frankly having been
around other people
that maybe have actually had that
responsibility uh and but this is
probably something common to a lot of
entrepreneurs but you trust yourself in
your own judgment more than you trust
other people's you'd rather be
responsible for your own destiny you
know what i mean like you and now
i will also say that i've been in
situations where i'm very very happy to
entrust uh the responsibility to someone
else who's better situated you know like
if you're on safari and there's like a
freaking guide you're like hey
like let me give this to you but uh you
know i i i have a lot of confidence in
my own
uh we said something in my own ability
to make decisions i want to hear a
little more so he said i
if you saw some people that i saw i
fully have more confidence in me being
number one what did you see that got you
to be more confident about being a good
number one well this is one of the
reasons i ran for president uh pat
you've had this experience too i think
because of the fact that you've met so
many of us over this time so i started
an organization called venture of
america to train entrepreneurs and
during that time i met
you know three former presidents 20
senators governors members of congress
and after you have that experience uh
you don't come away necessarily thinking
wow these people are all amazing and are
capable of doing things i could never do
like instead you're like you know what
like i think i actually have you know
like the same level of uh overall
ability or competence or in some cases
frankly a bit higher i
addressed a group of entrepreneurs at
like ypo uh you know like uh or eos
organization yeah these like
you know ass kicking entrepreneur types
and i said something to them that was
honest and some people can judge me for
this but whatever i was like i would
trust these 30 ceos in this room
more to run the country than the people
who are currently actually doing so you
know what i mean because if you had like
a bunch of number ones of significant
organizations the way you're describing
pat i mean they make these decisions
every day
they're really
uh
results driven uh they're good at
building teams they can like develop
cultures and then you are around the
folks in dc and a lot of those people do
not have that experience or set of
qualities a lot of these political
figures have never run anything
and then you you and then we're judging
them not based on whether they can
operate but whether they can operate
politically whether they can just show
up uh you know there's a chapter in my
last book called priests of the decline
where like you know it's like we we've
reduced political figures to folks who
just make us feel a little bit better as
we go home
and the problems don't get solved like
that that's what we reduced folks to
so uh you know i i know what makes me
tick like you know if i got in there i'd
be like look i'm going to solve as many
problems as i can
and if you didn't like it then you can
vote me out and i'll find something else
to do you know like a lot of these
politicians are addicted
to the field the job if they don't have
that attention they wither you know
that's not what makes me tick at all
which i believe would make me a better
figure to actually make some of these
things happen yeah do you uh do you do
you think and uh by the way great answer
appreciate you for that but do you think
uh uh like i thought you were going to
say like if i hang out with some of the
people i got a lot of confidence i can
be a number one i thought maybe we were
going to say joe biden gives you a lot
of confidence because his videos on
c-span i'm sure they're very
inspirational for you but going back to
going back to uh this whole topic here
being a great number one you can smile
it's okay if you want to smile like
that's okay every once in a while i tell
funny jokes but do you think do you
think your
ability
to
get dirty because it's very dirty you
seem like a really nice guy okay
and your answers are
if this is like pushing the envelope
where trump's gonna be bam bam bam bam
bam pushing the envelope if you know
clinton was not afraid to go bam bam bam
bam or even kamala hey uh you know vice
president joe biden i remember when you
were this and what you did with the bus
and holy [ __ ]
boom she goes here right
and i think when you did that with ubi
the idea was so crazy where the world's
like holy [ __ ]
that's pretty pretty crazy you kind of
poked a little bit but do you think
maybe you've gone a little bit safe and
a little bit too nice where you're
afraid to poke the bear to make a lot of
noise and maybe that's part of your
strategy i don't know maybe i'm wrong
again i'm just i'm just the business guy
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
just simply asking questions from you
yeah you know about i i think different
occasions uh call for a different type
of energy i mean i've led rallies of
thousands of people and then you go into
rally mode uh you know right now i'm in
uh
in party building mode um which is like
look uh you know that we can sense that
this system is not working and our
children deserve better let's give them
better let's let's solve problems let's
give rise to a home for the people who
feel politically homeless
uh you know so there are different ways
i could make that case um maybe i'm
trying to make that case in a way that
people find like appealing and agreeable
and like you know there are other people
who might prefer more
hey you know fiery like uh you know the
countries
uh heading off a cliff and like we need
to do something about which by the way i
totally believe i mean i could present
that case too
but
uh you know i think there are different
occasions different times but one thing
that people who know me know is that and
this is something you suggest a little
bit earlier i mean i run companies man i
mean when it's winning time you you know
you go for you go for the win like i'm
i'm not
uh here to mess around i'm here to save
the country fair enough do you have some
callers you also got to give him credit
for one thing what's that he did kind of
you know you're you're one famous other
than ubi you remember your one famous
line when you kind of
took a jab at trump you're like i can do
math
it was like what was that line that you
did because you kind of
what i said was that the the opposite of
donald trump is an asian guy who likes
math
and then math uh is an acronym for make
america think harder which is what the
message you got you got in the mud a
little bit just real quick i want to
double back to this ubi so the idea is
you're going to give everybody over 18 a
thousand dollars a month is that
accurate that was what i was running on
yeah okay so that's 260 million people
okay and this was based on automation
taking away the jobs was the idea behind
it yep okay so forester predicts 1.4
million jobs are gonna be lost by by
2032. why not take that thousand dollars
a month and put it into a government
fund to retrain people to train them in
hard skills plumbers carpenters um
possibly into tech into coding why why
just give them the thousand dollars a
month because it it seems like a
band-aid problem than actually fixing
the root issue of things oh i'm all for
investing in apprenticeship programs and
vocational and technical education we're
under investing that stuff
enormously
right now the tough thing though is that
if you look at the success rates of
government-funded retraining programs
the success rates 10 to 15 percent and
that's not a typo i mean you're talking
about like an 85 fail rate
uh and and this goes back to the entire
politics thing it's like what is a
politician going to say we're going to
train all americans for the jobs of the
future right then you actually go to
that manufacturing town you know what
people are doing
they're not coding you know they're
they're drinking themselves to death and
um and getting more and more upset so we
should be doing what you just suggested
uh but i do think that we need to try
and
uh give people a foundation and as a
numbers guy i mean you look at the
numbers and they're freaking terrible
it's like relocation rates uh were
lower than they've been business
formation rates
deaths of despair up life expectancy
down i mean there are a lot of people
that like that the talking points just
are not working and we have to actually
do something that might help does that
help you out
ish but we'll get to college okay john
do we have any callers yes we have phil
on the line phil how are you phil
phil can you hear us
yes i can thank you for taking my call
honored honor to be here
uh phil richard from the cayman islands
here i have a question for mr yang in
regards to universal basic income
i used to be a big supporter of
universal basic income and would
actually go on my local radio shows
um on on island and talk about ubi but i
just localized it
um
you know for the local audience and you
know people were a big fan of it and i
was too until covet happened and then i
saw members of the community who lost
their jobs because of covid but then
when their jobs came back they were very
comfortable with the government stipend
and didn't want to go back to work and
that's when i realized i don't think
this uh program can work
but
my
uh as an alternative i have is four day
work weeks i believe a four day work
week could work out you know it would
give people that you know
a the wheels of capitalism will keep
turning and b people have more time to
you know live their life hang out with
their friends and whatnot i'd like to
hear mr yang's opinion on a four-day
work week and congratulations mr yang on
your freedom oh no your forward party i
think it's awesome
thank you phil congrats to you on living
in the cayman islands
uh uh so i've i've run businesses uh you
know i've worked in various settings and
i think we all know what happens
sometimes when you come in on friday uh
where you're you're you're not actually
working that hard
like
not around here andrew yeah no no i hear
it's hard working all the time i know
but the the and and you know i'm a
pretty hard working guy but uh you know
work tends to expand or contract to fill
the time you give it you know if you
give yourself
uh six hours to get something done
magically it's going to get done in six
hours
if you you give yourself 20 hours it'll
take you 20 hours
um so as a numbers guy the stats around
four day work weeks are really positive
uh productivity sometimes goes up uh
well it goes up i'm talking about like
in total like you actually get more done
in four days than you do in five days in
other instances
increases worker loyalty and
satisfaction
uh improves uh mental health and like
you know sick days
um so all the data indicates that we
should be at a minimum experimenting
with four day work weeks and more
environments and organizations and a
maximum uh implementing it broadly
uh so you know huge fan of the four-day
work week uh and thank you phil for for
suggesting it
fantastic thank you phil anybody else uh
uh that we have john yeah we have gil on
the line
gil how you doing
hey how's it going fantastic what's on
your mind
so uh i love andrew yang i actually live
in new york city i live in the bronx and
i voted for you in the primary thank you
um and so i wanted to just share a
question i had about student loans you
touched on it briefly you talked about
sort of like going forward how to stop
the bleeding but i wanted to talk about
like the debt bomb that we have you know
we have about 1.6 trillion dollars of
student loan debt in america yep on the
on the you know i just want to know how
you would go about resolving it on one
hand you have many borrowers that just
that you just you have a lot of
borrowers who literally cannot pay it
back and then on the other hand if you
forgive it you're you know kind of
screwing over people who did pay it back
or paid tuition
uh the first time around so i just want
to know how you would deal with that
huge debt bomb that we have
now well thank you thanks for the call
and the support uh a lot of that money
uh it was
taken out uh excessively under you know
if not false pretenses at least kind of
exaggerated pretenses on the part of
these universities um i had 100k in uh
school loan debt myself for a while i
used to call it my mistress because you
know
write a check and be like i hope i hope
they're happy at the next tout or
wherever the money was going um but that
there is a fairness issue i also think
would be a great economic stimulus
because you know the money that you
forgive it's going to end up getting
spent a lot of these borrowers uh you
know are on the younger side you want
them to be able to buy a home to raise a
family all of this other good stuff
um so i i'd be if i were president right
now it'd be looking at much more
aggressive
uh like forgiveness forbearance uh you
know if you are gonna owe it we can like
adjust the interest rate and and make it
so that it's something that you can
actually pay
um
and if there are other people that you
know i either
um didn't go to college or already paid
off their debt you know like if there's
some way that we can say look we're not
going to do exactly for you we're doing
for these folks who are dead holders
like i'd like to do that for you too
because you know like you don't you
don't want to be
unfair for folks who made different
decisions it's one reason why i you know
i liked something that was broad and
universal
but given the way the system's designed
right now if i were in joe biden's chair
i would be much more aggressive about
trying to get people out from one of
these debt loads because it's a stimulus
and like you said
a lot of these people are not gonna be
able to pay this money back
it's a lot it's a lot of numbers right
then but what do you think about how
much college cost of college is
increased it's so so this is the thing
that drives me nuts too it's like and
this is something i would play at the
feed of democrats because like for
democrats colleges can do no wrong
hospitals can do no wrong and you look
at and be like wait a minute these
hospital prices make zero sense it's
like you know you can drive 60 miles and
the surgery is like 300 percent uh more
or less
college just goes up and up and if you
look at the returns on college
uh you know returns on college relative
not going to college okay you know you
can still make the argument that a
college pays so there are a lot of show
there are factors in there
um but that the the cost of college
going up is a result primarily of them
becoming really bloated bureaucracies
they've just hired like a gazillion
administrators if you ask people why why
is college so much more expensive
they'll say like the buildings no it's
not the buildings the buildings actually
rich people are happy to
make money together
yeah like you just wind up with like
really really complicated tangled
bureaucracies and then you pass that
cost along with families and then the
families who can't pay it you know where
they pass along to
like the government because they just
turn around and be like hey that's like
the vast majority it says federal
student loan that's 1.6 trillion like
that that's you know that that's out of
the government
so so it it's there's like no
accountability you have to go to
universities and be you know one of the
things i was saying too is like you look
at harvard they're down it's like 30
billion or something like that right
i actually argued it's like look instead
of opening locations in shanghai or abu
dhabi like open one in ohio no one in
michigan you know he got a freaking tax
break to the tune of billions of dollars
it's like
like you know let's like try and
stimulate some some growth and activity
here anyway don't get me started you
said no democrats are not the ones who
are no so so democrats what they do is
and this is one of the the toxic things
you get firey at the end of the podcast
you're driving me nuts you just made a
powerful point but i got three minutes
left with you that was powerful right
you just said it but let him say this no
he did but the point is that's that's
the messaging because even with this
whole gas situation right oh look at how
much money exxon made well look how much
taxes you're charging in california
correct why is you know why is gab why
are we doing all these things so fine i
do think exxon needs to always say guys
we're going to take this much and do xyz
for gas but hey why don't we do
something here why don't we draw why
don't all of us kind of figure out a way
to make this work if you run a startup
and we're down to ten thousand dollars
on a bank account you may come to me and
say pat you're taking a three hundred
thousand dollar salary i'm taking 300. i
can go a year without salary can you yes
let's do it we own the company together
fine i got pain you got pain but it's
only
the business people and taxpayers take
pain it's only it's not let's all of us
take a little bit of the pain and figure
this thing out you made a very you got
me fired up right now
what gets you the most fired up i think
that's what pat wants to know is that
what you want to know no no no i i want
to know because i've listened to him
more than when he was on the campaign
trail i listened to his debates i think
he's very necessary an entrepreneur on
the left that comes out of nowhere we
need more stories like this i agree but
i also think to create some momentum
you're going to need to do a little bit
more of calling out rather than playing
safe because playing it's safe they're
going to destroy you playing safe trump
came and he didn't play safe he poked
everybody there then all of a sudden
said [ __ ] this guy's got some stuff i
think he needs to do a little bit more
poke and i may be wrong but that's just
mine he just spoke to something right
here if i can add on to it very very
fast it says you know measure john do
you have do you have on us on the call
please text me go ahead um
you have the student load debt i said
136 billion dollars is the private debt
which means that the public school
debt's 147.
i mean i'm from 1.4 1.47 trillion which
means that there is 10 times the student
loan debt if i went to university of
nebraska than if i went to harvard 10
times and so when bernie sanders says
let's forgive all the student loan debt
there's something to be said for the
systems that have made it so unbearable
and unpayable but it's also basically
what he's saying is let's forgive
ourselves so that's the state systems
that are running state universities that
are completely bloated so to your point
it's and people like to poke out oh it's
harvard and it's yale and it's all these
things charged well no
that's not true the statistics show that
there's 10 times student loan debt on
state colleges anders and private
colleges well i believe that because if
you look at the harvards and yales of
the world they're so rich that they
actually can you know essentially take
poor kids in and say don't worry we'll
cover your cost i don't know if you want
for a hundred years for a hundred years
harvard can do that for 100 years a
hundred percent of their students every
year they can take a hundred percent of
the students they have and not take a
penny from them for 100 years they can
do that you know what they don't do they
don't actually expand their student body
like if you had those level of resources
which they do correct then you'd want to
uh do more good expand but they don't do
that because it would reduce their
selectivity and their prestige and and
the rest of it um so they just go around
you know jitting up the endowment per
student ratio instead of saying look
let's get some more students in live we
got a lot of people that want to talk to
you let's do one last one and wrap up
john do you have anybody for us yes we
have anna's okay anna's what is on your
mind on us
hello pat how are you doing today i hope
you're doing well god bless you happy
ramadan okay so my first question it's
it has to do with freedom of speech
basically and
hello yes yeah we can hear you go for it
yeah so when it comes to the economic
and economic freedom and political
freedom when it comes to israel for
example the republicans on the on the
right they censor pro-palestine advocacy
that's number one and when palestinians
they do business or when palestinian
advocates do business they're not
allowed to do business with the
government because they criticize israel
in my opinion
i look you have the right to criticize
the iranian government i don't mind
that's you that's your freedom of speech
but when it comes to israeli crimes or
saudi crimes to be honest with you i
don't see you talking about it the same
way how you talk about iran or turkey or
afghanistan and in my opinion this is my
personal opinion i respect you as an
individual i respect your show but i
don't see the same criticism against the
israeli government so my question to
keep it short
how come the israelis they could censor
palestinians and censor the american
people
uh again criticizing israel but it's
okay for other governments to become
another is this question for is this
question for uh uh
for andrew both of you both of them uh
patrick because andrea also had comments
when it came to israel he was very
pro-israel when israel was killing my
people and they were massacring us in
gaza not too long ago so i wanted to
answer that question also
um so and i got it i got the question
thank you pat for having me on us first
of all i appreciate the question and
you're always active listening
uh whether we agree disagree the fact
that you're always on here we appreciate
you being on here so andrew i respect
you because you allow freedom of speech
from both sides that's why i'm always
going to watch this thank you succeed
and i hope you value teammate gets on
the flash screens hopefully appreciate
it god bless you patrick and have a good
day i hope you become a business
go ahead andrew
now it was a tragic situation
uh you know last year uh and like just
about i mean everyone just wants people
to be able to peacefully co-exist i mean
when i was running for president my
stance was that there should be a
two-state solution
uh which uh i still hold and i i think
that that's something that a lot of
people desire and i wish it was
something that was more achievable
um in addition to us wanting to be that
way
um certainly you know i i have many
friends who are uh israelis and and
jewish and i have friends who are
uh palestinian
and from i think a human perspective we
all just want
uh want people to be able to co-exist
peacefully
yeah i know i would say the following
and to wrap up uh on one end is the
following you're right hollywood is
owned by who
uh uh the jewish community that that's
what they own they own hollywood but
what is capitalism done
capitalism's kind of opened it up where
other companies are allowed to bring
other stories in
independently what i would encourage you
to do on us is the following this is
what i'm doing okay let me tell you what
i'm doing i had oliver stone here in
this seat two weeks ago was it two weeks
ago two three two two or three weeks ago
right
and i saw oliver stone go to russia and
interview putin
multiple times multiple times over a
four-month period he he goes and does a
documentary on ukraine he goes and does
a documentary on jfk he goes and does a
documentary on what he his life
mission was to bring attention to the
things based on
his experience of going to world war ii
his father all that other stuff do you
have such fire behind us on us my
suggestion to you is team up with
somebody
create a podcast
write about it give your opinions out to
bring guests in go make a ton of money
make documentaries make short clips get
your voice heard and let the right
audience decide that's the great thing
about america ain't nobody going to take
your videos off if you want to talk
about palestine again against israel let
people decide that's america for you and
some are going to say you have no clue
what the hell you're talking about some
are going to say i agree with you and
then we can have the debate so that's my
challenge to you instead of doing a lot
of the screaming what you're doing i
want you to keep screaming but i want
you to make some money use the money
produce the content give your argument
team up with people that team up with
you and unless that argument be decided
amongst the people anyways but
appreciate the calls from everybody
andrew uh this was a bless having you on
man i really enjoyed it appreciate you
for coming out appreciate the heck out
of you and again i am here because this
man offered obama and trump five million
dollars to get together an event i was
like that's the kind of american we need
to get behind so
i love it i'm looking forward are you
willing to throw in on that create some
momentum yeah i would throw in there for
sure nice something tells me you at
least give a thousand bucks a lot of
people a lot of people would like to see
that andrew any last projects for people
that can follow you what's the place to
send them would you like us to send them
to a book or your site for forward party
uh yeah so forwardparty.com i wrote a
book called forward that's about this
movement if you want to try and move on
from our corrosive politics uh of
yesteryear like we can do it together
and we have to do it together because
without us it's not going to get any
better there you go the link is below in
description as well as the chat box as
well as the comment section andrew
thanks for coming out folks tomorrow we
will have with us joe jorgensen
libertarian candidate who ran for
president take care everybody bye bye
bye bye bye bye everyone entrepreneurs
unite bye everyone
you